it is time for hatred mail if you are
new to hatred mail here is what hatred
mail is because it's God's divine plan
that every child be born but an act of
patriotic duty to snuff that bastard if
he sets a foot near your stuff Patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom right so lately the criticism
from hatred mail has been not only
coming to me but increasingly pat has
been getting hit by shrapnel and that is
indeed the case with this week's hatred
mail take a listen to this who is this
clown with mic [ __ ] the whole Pakman
stumbled upon this channel looks like I
found a [ __ ] hangout have fun in your
echo chamber [ __ ] Hackman and is of
co-hosts our week and Trump and the
Republican are strong haha so either
anti-semitism or homophobia are sort of
staples of hatred mail and that was
there it is worth barely even worth a
comment because it is such a trademark
of the hatreds but once again making the
argument that Pakman and is of co-hosts
our week I assume that means you right
manned is up co-hosts yeah I used to
think that hey treat male was funny when
they were just going after you yes not
noticing that I'm getting hit by
shrapnel as well it's suddenly not as
funny anyway so no no it's not funny and
it's not fun once the focus is on you
this has to be taken seriously very much
so and it's being taken so seriously
that we are actually doing another round
of new hatred mail banners you might
notice that we have these banners
because America because freedom there's
always different there's about a dozen
different banners in rotation right now
we are opening it up to add new banners
these are all audience submitted the
only requirement is that it be 1920 by
1080 in terms of the image size that's
it have at it whatever you want to do
and hopefully we'll be able to add a few
good ones and of course you can send
that to me david at david pakman
komm is my email address and we will
review those and hopefully have some new
hatred mail banners soon and lastly you
can turn hatred mail into something
positive we have a coupon code which is
hatred for the8 ER io t 4 zero that will
save you 40% off of memberships at david
pakman.com slash membership I'm just
sayin folks it will let you do some very
very important things serious things
once you remember